perhaps you saw President Trump at the
economic roundtable he was he was having
a panel discussion with some leaders and
one guy stood out in particular that guy
was Jack brewer Jack brewer addressing
the major unrest going on in the country
the racial protests and riots and the
the just overall discord and I thought
he made a really beautiful point I'm
praying to the Holy Spirit to put words
on my mouth right now
and I want a nation to hear me
we need the fear of God mr. president
you're the only Republican I've ever
voted for
[Applause]
I love that line mr. president you're
the only Republican I've ever wrote
abrasive what do you want throws his
hands up in the air that man Jack brewer
professor Jack Brewer is a former NFL
player and ordained minister CEO of the
brewer Group champion at Liberty
University's Falkirk Center and on June
20th
before this upcoming Trump rally will be
announcing the launch of the Council for
racial reconciliation in Tulsa Oklahoma
Jack thank you so much for being here
thank you I appreciate you having me man
thank you so Jack I loved a lot of what
you said and I want to get into it but
first I got to ask you that line was so
funny
he's Trump really the first Republican
you've ever voted for I gotta be honest
he's the only Republican I've ever voted
for any phrase in DC and you know I was
I got a minute man I grew up and you
know kind of brainwashed and yeah you
know I didn't really stand all the
issues and what they really meant I just
remember my dad and no family members
always telling me that you know if
you're black you gotta both Democrat
because Republicans aren't for black
people and like that voice was literally
like haunting me the entire time I was
walking in the booth because I love
Trump and I just I knew he was gonna
make change and be what we needed in
life I mean I gotta admit like he wasn't
easy to even admit that I did that but I
was like know what maybe if I just vote
for Trump on the Republican ticket and
then all Democrats alongside then maybe
my parents and my family members and
ancestors won't be mad at you know it's
funny I think even even beyond the
racial aspects there were a lot of
people who voted for Trump who could not
admit that they were voting for Trump
right because obviously there's the race
aspect that has been foisted on our
culture by the mainstream media but
there was the class aspect there was the
geographic I mean there was just so many
different levels to this I got to ask
you though what was it about Trump I
mean what about this guy made you think
like okay everything I've been told
about politics I'm gonna disregard
because I feel like this is the right
guy first off he was in half of the rap
songs that I grew up listening to and
Rob in my head too right so you know he
was a part of black poetry always had
and it was like you know you wanted to
like go out and grind and be like trunk
you know and so it was just so ironic
that you saw the entire black culture
shift against him once you start running
for president and if you you know trying
to make him out to be a racist and you
know if you just listen to him and you
see how he was treated that's why I
called him the first black black
president
they treat him like a black man right
and treat him like the treated MLK and
Malcolm X didn't FBI after him and I
mean they don't treat this guy very well
and you know I can I can relate to that
so I can relate to his struggle and I
also I like people that are real you
know when I played an NFL
I love the coaches that told me just how
it was didn't sugarcoat anything and
maybe I didn't like their tone of the
wood or the way they said it but I sure
like you know winning football games you
know playing for Tom Coughlin you know
you may not like how he ran his team but
he won game yeah so you know I learned a
lot from that that's right the idea you
like to win and you like to know where
you stand I mean that's the thing with
Trump right is he doesn't he doesn't
talk pretty he doesn't you know use the
nuance soft political words he says
things that are rough and maybe you
don't like but you know where you stand
with him you know what he means I mean I
remember he he said he was gonna move
the embassy in his real to Jerusalem
this had been US policy officially for
two decades and yet every candidate
they'd say they were gonna do it no one
thought anyone would do it because we
just expect politicians to say one thing
and not really mean what they say then
Trump goes ahead and does it and
everybody's shocked that he actually
meant what he said and that's just one
example among many I want to focus Jack
for a moment on what you said there I
thought was so profound you said the
thing they were missing the most
important thing we got to get back to is
fear of the Lord fear of the Lord also
known as humility is another word for
that and that's so contrasts with our
culture which now this month I mean
literally celebrates pride we've only
got about 30 seconds left but could you
could you expand on that a little bit
definitely I mean you watch it in the
kid now you see these kids that are out
there you know the folks that are
looting taking pictures in front of
burning buildings and burning up
churches that comes from the fear of God
to spit on a copper or to throw water on
a cop or attack a police officer that's
the lack of spirit of the fear of God
and I think it's been systematically
pushed through progressive policy in our
education system in our entitlement
system where we're encouraging women not
to get married giving a more welfare for
not being married and not build a family
unit
and it goes all the way back to
Scripture you know you know gender the
gender confused and that's going on
teaching kids they can pick their
genders oh it's just like no it's it's
all it's it's holiday and there's really
it's funny it's funny jack that you
mentioned the gender issue because
that's the one that just came up today
all the way up at the Supreme Court and
I think what you're saying is in many
ways it's a simple observation but in a
culture that's going so crazy it's one
that nobody else seems to be making I
really loved it I loved what you said I
can't wait to hear more jack on the 20th
right before that rally in Tulsa if you
enjoyed that break from the
disinformation the historical revision
and the screaming about the end of the
world be sure to hit the subscribe
button so you never miss another video